next professor Gordon s wood details
Benjamin Franklin's transformation from
loyal British subject to revolutionary
and founding father the Americanization
of Benjamin Franklin is his new book
this talk is an hour good evening
welcome to the National Constitution
Center I'm Rick Stengel I'm the new
president of the National Constitution
Center and it gives me great great
pleasure to welcome Gordon wood here
it's a little bit like welcoming Ben
Franklin the Constitution Hall because
professor wood had so much to do with
actually creating this place he's more
than just a good friend of the National
Constitution Center he's the head of our
distinguished scholars advisory board
and in that role his intellectual
fingerprints are all across this
building in fact his little blue book on
the American Revolution which is called
the American Revolution is kind of the
text of what helped create our show
freedom rising and our exhibition hall
and even more important to me it was the
first book I read when I got this job
three months ago so I have my annotated
text out stairs
professor wood has also been
instrumental in helping us reach out to
the academic community he's one of the
editors of our book series that were
doing with Penn Press called the
Constitution in America and this is the
third I believe of our constitutional
conversation series which is a series of
talks with distinguished writers and
scholars the best and the brightest in
America on constitutional issues and
professor wood is certainly one of the
best in the brightest he is the Alva
away university professor at Brown and
he is that rare historian who combines
great depth of knowledge incisive
insights about history with a really
lovely and elegant and accessible
writing style and that is makes his
books very easy to read and also
life-changing to read his first big book
that on the
American Revolution the creation of the
American Republic in fact changed the
way historians and the rest of us think
about the early days of our country and
the radicalism of the American
Revolution Proheat which he won a
pulitzer prize also showed how america
separated itself from britain how truly
radical this act was and how it
influenced the world to this day now
tonight we're going to be talking about
the Americanization of ben franklin and
that in fact is a revolutionary work
because in it professor would postulates
that ben franklin wasn't really a
revolutionary at all he was a closeted
royalist and he was a very very
different man than the man that we think
we know even though of course Ben
Franklin seems the most accessible of
all of our founders so we're going to
talk about Ben Franklin tonight and talk
about other issues as well and I want
you to help me welcome professor Gordon
wood
thank you thank you very much thanks
Rick now the first question Gordon is
the title the Americanization of Ben
Franklin is very resonant but what does
it mean well I guess I'm I'm running
against the grain I think most people
and I certainly thought that America
that Franklin was the first American and
the most American of the founders but
when I got into his papers I realized
that he was probably of all the
revolutionary leaders the last of the
Americans to join in the revolution he
did join in he was a revolutionary when
he when he came came late and he came
with a real passion but he certainly was
not destined to be an American and to be
the kind of symbolic American that he
became there's a lot of contingency a
lot of events occurred that made him an
American and I'm concerned with those
important events that really transformed
his life at key points this is not a
traditional biography it's not like
Walter Isaacson's or Calabrian Doran's
it's not a full study of every aspect of
Franklin's life but it focuses on key
points that bring him to us as Americans
that make him an American he wasn't
destined to be an American and at points
he came very close to spending the rest
of his life abroad after all he spent
most of his adult life in Europe but
he's for most of us he is this symbol of
early to bed early to rise of capitalism
of rags to riches and yet you suggest in
the book that his real aspiration was to
be a gentleman and you talked a little
bit about that well yes I and actually I
hope you've got a handout I think this
helps explain what my book is about and
what that era was about on one side of
the and if you don't all have one maybe
you can share it the on one side will
have a portrait of there's two portraits
here on one side we have Benjamin
Franklin 17:48
this is his coming out portrait he had
this painted
at that moment he became a gentleman
which was a big deal in the 18th century
not for us everybody every male's the
gentleman now and put the term on our
restroom doors but it meant something in
the 18th century a commoner a person who
worked no matter how wealthy as long as
he was engaged in business even if he
had 20 employees as long as he went to
work and was occupied as a printer or a
tradesman he could not be a gentleman a
gentleman was a man of leisure Franklin
amassed enough wealth and he was very
wealthy by 1748 to retire permanently
from business he never worked a day in
his life again of course he was busy he
did a whole host of things but not
overtly working for profit for working
for money and this portrait was painted
on the occasion of his of his coming out
so to speak as a gentleman he moves to
loo quarters he moves away from his shop
he buys two slaves he now is engaged in
philosophical amusements as he said
science and more importantly public
service which a man of leisure could do
as a gentleman I on the other side of
the of the page is a second portrait
seventy-five years later which may be
familiar to some of you because there's
one there are two copies in existence as
far as I know one is at the Museum of
Fine Arts in Boston and the other is at
the Pennsylvania Museum this is Pat Lyon
at the forge painted by Ralph Nagel in
1826 Pat Lyon is a wealthy businessman
but he does not want his portrait
painted as a gentleman he says that
today go I want to be painted the way I
was the way I began as a blacksmith in
my leather apron that's a new kind of
portrait he's flaunting his humble
origins and I would submit to you the
difference between these two portraits
is the radicalism of the
culture have changed so much and
Franklin is important part of that
change because he becomes a symbolic
hero to people like pat lion who are now
rising businessmen who are not ashamed
of the fact that they work and they they
want to flaunt the fact that they began
as humble blacksmiths or tradesmen or
printers whatever and and and lion is
doing that and the fact that he can get
away with that is a is a measure of the
cultural change that's taking place and
Franklin as the only founder that these
businessmen can appeal to becomes their
hero and they use him over and over
again his autobiography of course is is
not published until after Franklin dies
the image we have a Franklin as the
boudoir America babba tree and Main
Street rolled into one the go-getter the
banana lifts himself by his own
bootstraps
that's an invention of the early 19th
century by people like Pat Lyon who make
him their hero and of course being the
spokesman for business and capitalism
he becomes the object of scorn for a
host of imaginative writers so everybody
from Paul to Thoreau to Melville to
Twain culminating with D H Lawrence as
vicious attack on Franklin in the 1920s
they heaped scorn on this bourgeois
middle-class money-making capitalist and
Max Weber of course picks up Franklin as
the symbol of capitalism that's an
invention of the 19th century it's an
invention that the people like Pat Lyon
so those two portraits I think framed my
argument and and I think that's Franklin
is important both as a living figure as
a great scientist who is celebrated
throughout the world for scientific
achievements and then also as this visua
self-made man which is a creation of the
curse after he dies with the use of the
republication of the
the autobiography which is probably the
most widely published autobiography in
the world host of translations and the
way to wealth and all of his poor
Richard Maxim's which are all designed
to make money but let me challenge you
on one thing you in the book you have
that wonderful quote where Franklin says
he's he's trying to be humble and he's
trying to embrace humility but he's not
very good at it but it's often very
useful to at least have the appearance
of it rather than the reality of it and
he talks about how even after he became
wealthy in Philadelphia he would
sometimes carry his papers the stock of
papers through the streets so people
would say oh well he's really still a
tradesman wasn't he complicit in the
making of his own mythology wasn't he in
the autobiography in the aphorism
support Richard wasn't he thinking well
I want people to think this about me and
I want this ideology to go out there I
don't think I don't think he was doing
this until the very end of his life the
autobiography of course was not
published he wrote the first part and
maybe where you can develop the context
for that because I don't find the
literary people who spend a page after
page book after book analyzing the
autobiography nobody as far as I know
analyzes the context for the writing of
it he that's written that first part in
1771 is written in a mood of deep
depression his highest ambitions in the
British Empire he wants to have an
office a political office in the higher
in the Imperial hierarchy and he's
denied it and he's really thrown into a
depression he travels around the British
Isles in funk going from country house
to country house now one of those
country houses of a friend he begins
writing the autobiography the first part
which is the address to his son William
and it's written I think in a mood of
kind of defiance look he's saying I I'm
an independent man I don't need to have
some Lords patronage I'm not a Lackey of
some peer of the realm I can made it on
my own
look what I did that's what he's saying
there's a defiance there and
in a sense he's also saying to his son
look kid this is how dad did it I don't
want you to keep asking me for more
money because his son is royal governor
of New Jersey but has is a gentleman
from the beginning never worked a day in
his life and is constantly asking his
father for funds because the New Jersey
Legislature is not paying him enough so
it's it's written in that mood when the
signals from the British government
change Hillsboro his enemy who's a
hardliner is ousted as the head of the
American Department and his friend
Dartmouth is appointed Franklin drops
the Autobiography completely just lets
it go he and moat no more emotional need
for it and he doesn't pick it up again
until the end of the French mission in
1784 so there are particular reasons why
he does that he never goes around once
he's a gentleman he doesn't go around
Philadelphia flaunting his obscure
origins there are people who know where
he came from and they he probably had to
endure a thousand snubs and and remarks
but he overcomes these by sheer
brilliance and by assimilating the
gentry standards he knows more than any
other gentleman he he learns about five
languages he makes himself the equal of
anybody in the world in his own mind and
I think in the minds of the people
around him he works hard at this but
he's got sheer genius that elevates him
he certainly does not go around while
he's a gentleman talking about he I was
once a printer and bragging about that
he does that in the autobiography but
it's not something that he does in his
life talk a little bit about because if
we of course think of Franklin as these
anti British patriot talk about his
royalism his sense of himself as a
British subject his great belief in the
British Empire which you write about
quite a bit I actually got started in
this book when I reviewed some of the
papers which are published of course by
the Yale University Press this meant
magnificent letterpress edition I was
reviewing them in the 1970s in the years
of of the seventeen 50s and early 60s
and I read these letters and I said this
is not the Frank
I know because he's talking about how
great George the third is and what a
wonderful place England is and how
anybody could live in America without
parochial narrow-minded people and the
place is so far away from civilization
and how I mean his his excitement about
London rivals Samuel Johnson's
excitement in other words he says
anybody who who once lived in London
could never live anywhere else he is
totally committed cosmopolitan Brit and
a loyal subject of George the third
he's so enthusiastic about the monarchy
that even some of his British friends
are stunned at how how much he admires
Lord Butte for example and and George
the third so that got me thinking that's
not the Franklin I know what is this
this man sounds like a totally like a
future Tory or future loyalist and and I
think he was I think he was an incipient
loyalist and and if the British
government had played their cards right
the British government played his cards
right they could have kept him as they
kept his son he was after all appointed
in 1762 as governing a royal governor of
New Jersey largely through Franklin's
influence there's no reason why if the
British had been wise they could have
given him the kind of office he wanted
essentially to be second-in-command in
the new American department that is
created in 1767 68 the British finally
woke up to the fact that these North
American colonies deserve their own
cabinet department and the first
appointed secretary was Lord Hillsboro
Franklin couldn't have been the head of
it because these were all peers of the
realm but he would have been second in
command so to speak the Wolfowitz
Wolfowitz under rumsfeld if you will
something like that so he
but the British don't do that hillsboro
blocks the appointment and that's when
he goes into this funk that leads to the
autobiography then of course he gets
very excited about when the Dartmouth
comes in and he thinks that he can solve
the problem with the aid of Dartmouth
and that's when he did engages in the
hutchinson letters the fear which
essentially destroys his his political
standing in England I don't know let's
well let's naturally let's talk about
now what changed him what what
radicalized him I mean what you know in
some ways it seems almost psychological
hell hath no fury like a gentleman
scorned in England then what is
something to that he the Hutchinson
affair reveals some of the naivete I
think of a friend he always had this
confidence that a few wise men can solve
a fears if we could just get rid of them
the populist they're too passionate and
so he what he does with the Hutchinson
letter he gets a hold of these letters
written by governor lieutenant governor
Hutchinson in the 1760s written by
Hutchinson to a friend in England where
he unfortunately makes the remark that
several remarks along the line is we
need to curb some American liberties if
we're going to solve this in a period
crisis well this is embarrassing stuff
and Franklin gets a hold of it and says
aha I'm going to send this to
Massachusetts and I'm going to show the
Massachusetts radicals who of course are
way out in front that the problem of the
crisis is is due to people like native
officials like Hutchinson this will in
turn absolve the ministry the cabinet
back in England from responsibility for
the crisis and will allow me and
Dartmouth to to settle this affair and
of course he couldn't have been more
wrong the thing just blows up in his
face it backfires completely and he is
attacked viciously in the cockpit which
is an amphitheater in Whitehall by the
Solicitor General
I was in the weather burned in a
diatribe which is so vicious that the
British press can't publish the whole
thing it's that it's that nasty Frank
and the whole court is in attendance
laughing and clapping and and Franklin
stands mode without any showing any
emotion for an hour and then it's
supposed to have said to whatever and
when he walked out of the cockpit he's
supposed to have said Jim I'll make you
a master a little King for this weather
he said it or not we don't know except
that that's was reported later he is
angry he's been humiliated now he this
is in 74 January he lingers on another
year largely because Lord Chatham that
is William Pitt with a title solicits
his help and he's flatted by this
because Pitt is the great man
although Pitt and charged as Chatham is
out of touch with with mainstream
politics at this point he's marginalized
he does make a last-ditch peace offer
peace arrangement presents it to the
House of Lords with Adam with with
Franklin's advice but it's hooted down
in the House of Lords as an American
proposal and and they point to Franklin
and who's sitting in the gallery it's
his proposal and Chatham is furious but
the thing never goes anywhere it doesn't
even get a second reading the British
government at this point is bet on
revenge especially for the tea party and
so Franklin says I got to get out of
here because his lawyer said you're
going to be arrested if you don't get
that get back to America so he leaves in
March of 1775 with as a passionate
Patriot he it comes with an anger that
even stuns John Adams of course there's
no slouch when it comes to Haiti they
can't the others can't believe that he's
so angry but part of that is calculated
because a lot of people suspicious of
Franklin
he's accused of being a spy James
Madison is who gets word from him from
college roommate we neglected that
people think Franklin's a spy Madison a
great lover of Liberty the author of the
Bill of Rights that says well when they
smoke this fire he probably is a spy but
then things change because Franklin
works at it showing that he's a real
Patriot so part of us his passion is
calculated but I think part the other
half is is real he actually writes this
outrageous letter to Williams Trahan
this lifelong English friend short
letter more or less says look you've got
blood in your hands you've destroyed our
property you bombarded our cities you're
a bunch of killers and I you are my
enemy and I am yours Benjamin Franklin
he doesn't matter it's not just outrages
but he shows it around Philadelphia and
he convinces people that he is a patriot
he can write that kind of letter to his
close friend then he must be really
cutting his ties so I think the passion
is partly calculated but more so I think
more I think it's real he is angry he's
been humiliated in a way none of the
other founders or revolutionary leaders
were so he comes at the revolution with
a personal passion it's it's very
personal for him in a way that it's not
I think for the other leaders I'm gonna
ask a couple more questions and then
we're gonna open it up to questions from
you out there so start thinking about
them so you've taken us a little
chronologically he's now back in
Philadelphia right talk about his role
at the Constitutional Convention well
that comes later
that's after France oh we were in 7576
he stays one year he does a lot of
things they give him a whole host of
jobs he's everywhere he does everything
but he mainly wants to get back to
Europe so the first opportunity as soon
as they need a they think about well we
need an agent in in France to bring
France into the on our side he's his
hand is up I'm ready to go and of course
he's the natural he he's much more at
home abroad because he feels as he says
at many points during this time I'm
mister
in my own country after all between 1757
and 1785 he spent only three years back
in America he's abroad either in London
or Paris through all that time with poor
suffering Deborah hearing Philadelphia
so he gets back to Europe and works
brilliantly he is I think the second
most important founder and indispensable
to the revolution second only to
Washington
I think his his support is is crucial to
keeping the French as an ally not just
for the support of the troops but more
important for the funds that he was able
to extract from an increasingly
impoverished French government the
French give he gets extracts long after
loan from versions the Chief Minister
and France eventually bankrupts itself
and prepares the way for the French
Revolution and it's only Franklin could
have done that because none of the other
agents commissioners Adams orally or
Arthur Lee could have done it they were
persona non grata two to two versions
and the French government but Franklin
sike silently the French knows what they
want a bunch of aristocrats who have
this imagined Mirage in the West if you
will and imagine America they think of
it as simple egalitarian filled with
Quakers they think Franklin's equate
there they assume everybody in
Pennsylvania's a Quaker and it's the
Quakers are noted for their tolerance
and so on and Franklin plays this role
to perfection at the court of Versailles
which is the most elaborate the most we
find the most protocol ridden court in
all of Europe where nobody dares move
for fear of violating one rule or
another he shows up in a linen coat no
wig no sword and the French aristocracy
they love it there's their of course
they're going through a period of
radical chic criticizing themselves
singing songs in favor of Liberty
republicanism they go to to hear
Mozart's The Marriage of Figaro which of
course as you know mocks the aresty
you see in the aristocracy the lifes it
I mean these are the French I mean what
can you do with the people living that
believe that Jerry Lewis is the greatest
comedian since Charlie Chaplin so they
follow this is the aristocracy this is
not the common people they're falling
over themselves they they have
medallions they have Franklin's image
every year on handkerchiefs on on all
kinds of items his faces as he says at
one point this his face is as familiar
as that of the man of the moon and and
he plays that long to perfection and
that he could only do that no one else
could he is the most celebrated American
in the world and the French loved it and
continued for loving more so than the
Americans did as it as he finds out when
it goes back so let's before we get to
him coming back
we had Cokie Roberts here the other day
talking about her book founding mothers
which is a companion to the founding
fathers and someone in the audience
asked her about Ben Franklin and she
just she grit her teeth and she could
hardly talk about him for all the rage
she felt about him as a husband and a
father talk about his well that's not a
its finest hour he he married Deborah as
a very young man largely because he
needed the as he said to get married
because he was frightened of getting a
VD he was a lusty young man and he
needed the marriage he said he proposed
to one woman but he asked for a dolly of
a hundred pounds and the parents turned
them down and so he takes up Deborah
Deborah may have been the only person in
Philadelphia who would have taken it
because he brings to the marriage a
illegitimate son from another woman a
baby she has to bring up this baby who
some other woman we don't know who she
is some other woman's child so she never
gets along with women so she was a
coarse loud
shrewd woman a good worker she certainly
contributed to his his wealth she ran
the shop she was a good store keeper she
was
may in that sense but there's no
intellectual companionship
she never accompanied him even when he's
a wealthy printer moving in Gentry
circles she didn't go with him so modern
times they would have divorced but they
stay together he leaves in 1757 she says
he says wanted to come but she knows
better she says I'm frightened of the
ocean but I think it's more than that
she knew that she could not move in the
sophisticated circles that he's meeting
in London he's moving at almost the
highest eventually at the highest
circles he's dining with kings he's
moving with the with the lords and
ladies of London
she couldn't have managed so she's
long-suffering and he has a surrogate
family with the stephenson so widowed
mrs. Stevenson and her daughter Polly
and it substitutes for his own wife and
daughter Sally back in Philadelphia and
it's rather sad because she writes near
the end she has a stroke and she's dying
and she says please come home I want to
see you before I die and he has led his
back full of business see that the
accounts are to get the rent from
so-and-so land and it's just for funk
tree business letters there's not a
there's no affection there so he was he
was thinking her thinking of her at this
point as simply his his business partner
so it's a sad state so let's bring him
back from France France he comes
well his friend he comes back to from
France he knows at this point that his
destinies linked with America although
he proposes to Madame delicious and says
to her if you accept me I'll stayed the
rest of my life in France he would love
to have stayed in France but at this
point a Quaker friend in fact two Quaker
friends have read or have heard about
his first part of his autobiography in
manuscript and they say suddenly Kalin
look you've got to continue this because
you're the representative America you're
going to be the spokesman for the rising
people and they everyone senses at this
point that the American Revolution is is
a world historic event and Franklin's
and suddenly he realizes that this
autobiography has to be expanded so he
writes the second part which is which
assumes man's control over events it
comes out of his experience in France
where he felt he was he was conducting
politics the way he liked to as a single
person in control like a chess game he
says and that's this model for politics
it was back to America it's a stranger
in his own country outside of
Philadelphia
he has enemies everywhere he there are a
lot of people who love him here they
elect them to the to the executive
council there's no governor in
Pennsylvania at that point there's an
executive council he's elected president
by that council for three years in a row
Washington thinks he's out of his mind
to accept offices why is he doing this
is it old man he's 80 years of age why
is he doing this
he tells I think his sister I shouldn't
be doing this but I can't help but that
everybody is so suspicious of me and
they dislike me so much I need the vent
my vanity requires me to to get elected
he needs this the feeling of being
accepted
it's a rather sad because he's attacked
by the Congress he's treated shabbily by
the Congress he is reduced to writing
out in 1788 to his friend Charles
Thompson who's the only person he knows
it connected with the Congress which
itself is significant services rendered
by B Franklin to the United States and
he lists them and he says please present
this to the president of the Congress he
doesn't know who that B doesn't know the
president the Congress which itself I
thinks is symbolic of or symptomatic of
his of his strangeness is estrangement
and the Congress and he wants his
grandson to be looked after be given an
office somewhere in Europe he speaks
French fluently he's been my secretary
please do something for it
Congress ignores just neaten give it
doesn't even give a response one other
fact that gives you some idea of where
he stands with with the elite Washington
when he dies 10 years later there are
400 eulogies printed
nevermind all those that were given all
over that you don't know about they were
printed 400 eulogies frankly gets one
one eulogy given by William Smith is
inveterate enemy Smith is given the job
because he's vice president over the
American Philosophical Society over here
and he says you've got a they you got to
do it and he delays a year he's not his
heart's not in it he doesn't like
Franklin their enemies so he finally
gives it because the French embarrassing
the French have eulogy after eulogy and
they send them to the United States and
the eulogies flood in and suddenly
people say gee we've got to do something
thing and so they Smith finally gets his
you and it gets up enough gumption to
give you energy which is a half heart of
the fear you can read it he apologizes
for his for his humble background will
pass over that it's kind of embarrassing
he says and we move on he wasn't much of
a politician he says they don't like
Franklin's attachment to France they
don't like the fact that he favored a
unicameral legislature which
Pennsylvania had of course for a decade
they don't like a lot of things about
Franklin and so he praises his
scientific achievements but it's a
really disappointing performance
symptomatic of the feelings that people
had towards Franklin at the elite
certain elites the Adams is in
Massachusetts the LEAs in Virginia from
both ends of the country he is disliked
the House votes a a month of mourning
and the Senate refuses to go along it
doesn't even get second the seconded the
motion is made and it's doesn't even get
seconded that's the reputation he had it
has something to do with Adams hostility
because Adams is in the Senate as vice
president and believes Lee is a Senator
Richard Henry we need not Arthur but
Richard heard the Lee family and the
fact that he had this close connection
with France he's seen in fact there's
being more loyal to France than he was
to the United States there's some
suggestion that he was creaming off
profits for himself there's no his they
won't close his accounts they hold that
over his head you haven't we haven't got
all your accounts straight we're not
sure of this a lot of suspicion of it
it's a sad moment for him he dies really
I think that a little anger Ekta and at
this moment he turns back to his printer
I think in these moments of despair he
looks back and says look I was somebody
then I made it that kind of and he talks
about it as a printer he says to his
grandson Benny
Sally's boy be a printer don't try to do
anything else because you can make it as
a printer and you'll be your own man you
won't have to kowtow to the public and
of course he does go Richard H goes on
to become a well-known publisher in
printer here in Philadelphia so Franklin
dies with a certain amount of
ambivalence about his Americans if you
will but after his death he becomes the
American we all know for the reasons I
suggested the Pat lines of the world
finding him the guy who can endorse what
they're trying to do justify their rise
and against these Federalist aristocrats
who are condemning them scornfully for
being workers or being Labour's there's
a celebration of work of working for
money that is unparalleled in the
Western world
it occurs in America first and to a
greater degree than ever any other
country there are good reasons why
college President Coolidge said that the
business of America is business business
came to dominate as you know our culture
in a way that it doesn't dominate French
or English culture and Franklin was the
important part of that the Pat Lyons of
the world were an important part of that
well that's a perfect moment to segue to
questions Liz has a microphone which you
can hand you and I think we want you to
stand up and ask the question it's a
gentleman right here in the front oh
Lisa thank you
when when I heard you to say something
about Franklin wanted to felt the need
to get married and things I started to
have that thought about well while it
was abroad all that time alone I mean I
don't know how appropriate a question
this is but do you know anything about
his affairs as far as did he engage any
of the French there's not a scrap of
evidence that would it's just your you
have to infer he's living as a hardy 50
he's in his 50s and early 60s when he's
in London living with mrs. Stevenson
who's a widow in the same apartments by
the way that house is going is going to
be open in 2005 for for American
visitors it's right off of Charing Cross
at a theatre site we have no evidence
other than your own in you can infer
probably but who knows he would be it
would be quite extraordinary we have no
evidence they like like Boswell that he
was engaging in with prostitutes that
probably would have come out so your
guess is as good as mine and then later
in France he certainly was flirted with
women I mean Abigail Adams was
astonished to find the link to one of
the salons and find Franklin sitting
there with Madame Helvetia or Madame
Dupree all sitting on his lap showing as
Abigail said showing more than her feet
too much skin showing and she just was a
you know abashed at this French behavior
the Franklin was a flirt he loved women
he loved their companies after both
sociable but we don't have any evidence
of hanky-panky he wanted to marry her he
asked her to marry him
oh no no this isn't friends this is
Debra dies in 1774 this is this is 1784
so ten years later he's he's what
seventy-eight she's in her 60s she's a
very charming woman according to all the
reports but he well he doesn't care it's
casually he he asked her to marry him
but he does it in such a way that she
could refuse without embarrassing him
but he says to I'll stay here if you
because she's not gonna come to America
I'll stay he also says if to I think the
Briana's if the Dion's
daughter will marry Bening these are one
of his grandson then he'll stay also so
there are two moments where he promises
to stay in France that's also evidence
of his aspiration to be a gentleman that
he says so in tight with the French
aristocracy well that's a little lady
that's he already is established he
doesn't need to to do that anymore he's
not the world-class celebrity by the
time he's in France Stewart you have to
stand up Gordon I wondered if you could
talk about his role in the anti-slavery
campaign yes he starts like most
Americans and most people in the world
without any question questioning slavery
one bitty by slaves owned slaves you
have to understand that slavery had
existed for thousands of years and
nobody virtually nobody in the world
question of it they begin questioning
Quakers here in Philadelphia begin
questioning and Franklin changes his
mind in the course of his life not just
comes against comes out against slavery
but more important I think this is where
he's truly enlightened it goes way ahead
of many of the other anti slave people
in that he realizes that we've got to do
more we've got to educate the free
blacks not only going to free them but
we've got to invest funds and education
these people he says need need help
they've been they've been victimized too
long so he makes all kinds of plans and
so on he becomes the head of the anti
slave Society President Lee
in Pennsylvania which is the leading
anti-slave Society Quaker driven in the
country and he signs a petition near the
end of his life to the Congress I think
in part Christmas this stirs up a
hornet's nest in Congress he knows it's
going to do it it hasn't got a chance
snowball's chance in hell going anywhere
in the Congress it's just going to stir
emotions and it does Jackson congressman
Jackson of Georgia it goes ballistic and
speech makes a terrific
unbelievable speech against it talking
about how we need slaves and who's going
to do the who's going to pick the cotton
and people need the climate is such that
whites can't work and it goes on and
they say it gives Franklin his
opportunity for his last hoaxes he
writes in the press a speech by a Muslim
leader Algeria to list who had been
capturing white sailors and imprisoning
them so he puts in the mouth of this
Muslim people who have been petitioning
the Muslim government to do away with
this white slavery said Wow Wow how we
won't be able to to to we to transform
them from from Christians to Muslims
which had been one of Jackson's
arguments this is the way we're going to
Christianize these blacks and who we we
can't work in the fields only these
White's can work in our fields because
they're adaptable to our climate he just
puts all of Jackson's arguments in the
mouth of this Muslim and it's a perfect
hoax and it's his last published piece
came out I think in March and he dies in
in April of 1790 so he's a firm
anti-slave advocate at the end of his
life more so than any of the other
founders
how about that gentleman right there Oh
blue Sporto
can you talk about the relationship
between Franklin and John Adams and why
that was such a strained relationship
well if you've read David McCullough's
book you know John Adams he's an honest
man he means well for his country but
his Frenchman said sometimes in some
things he's absolutely out of his senses
and that's France is a bull in a china
shop
over there in Paris he's never been
outside the biggest city had seen is
Philadelphia and he's awed by that he's
lacking in the kinds of diplomatic
discretion that's needed he's just
bumptious and honest there's no doubt he
says things two versions that nobody
could say it's just outrageous stuff he
if he had been left in sure I mean
Vergennes reached the point where he
says I do not want to talk to that man I
want no communication with him please
just keep him away from me
if they've been left to - Adams the the
rough there would have been a rupture
between the United States and France
he's just simply he just sees he sees
the alliance in terms of what France is
really lucky to be our ally that kind of
view and and Franklin can only shake his
head and say what is he
we're we're dependent on the French
French a French army and it's true
Washington could never have conducted
that siege it you'll be uptown without
Rochambeau Washington was a militia
colonel she didn't know anything about
conducting a siege it's the French army
that's very crucial but not just the
French army it's those months that money
that only Franklin could have got Adams
is a aegis well he's just that kind of
character and I think that statement
that I quoted from from Franklin I think
pretty well sums up John Adams he's an
honest man but he
not a great diplomat over here yeah but
this young man might have professor with
my questions actually two prong first in
your discussion you discuss the many
faces of Franklin how you in certain
ways crafted His image and yet in
certain other ways had an image crafted
for him I wonder if you could elaborate
on that and how as a historian you get
to what you consider to be the real
Franklin cutting through some of those
images and my related point is you know
for biographies in less than three years
seems to me that Franklin still hasn't
continuing relevance to historians and
to the general public and I was
wondering maybe if you could touch on
that and sort of discuss his place in
American historiography in society today
well I'll take the second part first I
think that of course the the the big
push is is is the fact that we're coming
up to the tercentenary of Franklin and
you folks here in Philadelphia are going
to get you a fill because 2006 is the
300th anniversary of Franklin's birth
and if you you have to wait till 2032 to
to get to George Washington's 300 M so
it's a long time which is a an important
fact is it he's a generation older than
the other other founders or the other
revolutionary leaders which I think
itself is it is important that helps
account I think for for the number of
the biographies but but I think Franklin
still has has relevance for the reasons
that I said I think he stands for social
mobility he stands for the American
dream if anyone stands for that it's
Franklin even though Hamilton for
example came from pretty low origins as
well and is kind of floated to the top
out of sheer brilliance its Franklin
because of the autobiography that I
think has come to represent the American
dream if you those of you read The Great
Gatsby is one of the great characters in
American literature Gatsby at one point
his father's describing how young Gatsby
kept kept the
scheduled for himself you know up at six
seven to six to seven exercises seven to
eight or read such-and-such I mean it's
a model done on Franklin and Gatsby of
course is the whole book is about the
fact that the American Dream recedes
from our grasp that
that's what Fitzgerald was playing with
so Franklin stands for that and as long
as there is this thing called the
American Dream I think that that would
be would be important now the images are
Frank Oh you obviously have read the
first chapter at least because I don't
think it's easy to get at Franklin
because of the mask series he writes as
with different personas both as a woman
as a man as a New Englander as a
Londoner he's got a thousand different
personas that he adopts and so it's been
difficult for literary people and
historians to get at the man and even
the simplest story can be misinterpreted
because he's so ironical he he says one
thing that then really turns and twists
at the end and so you're suddenly left
unclear about his point and you can
interpret it either way I don't think
it's easy to using the writings which
appear in the Pennsylvania Gazette or
appear in the London press to get at the
man he wrote for the moment and he wrote
for the agenda he at one time he's
writing as a colonial and they'll try to
explain the colonial point of view to
the English the next moment he's writing
as a London are trying to explain the
English point of view to the Americans
you don't want to say that he's one or
the other he's doing he's many many
voices but I do think and I've tried to
get at in the rest of my book what I
think the real Franklin was like it's
not easy because he's not like John
Adams he doesn't wear his heart on his
sleeve so there's a lot of room for for
interpretation
but I do think there are moments where
he reveals himself like that petition to
the Congress services rendered
like B Franklin that's a poignant moment
I think kind of sad moment that you
should have to write that that reveals a
lot I think at least I've tried to get
it what I think is the real Franklin
let's see the woman with glasses over
there on the right I just wondered if
you could comment on Franklin's role at
the Constitutional Convention was he
socially accepted was he kind of what
kind of a role did he play because it
seems as if he became more important at
that moment or maybe it's just according
to some histories I think he was the
cops we have people were kind of walk
they know he's a world-class celebrity
in that the great dr. Franklin one of
the one of the delegates mr. Georgia
says odd he tells the greatest doesn't
seem very he's quiet he doesn't talk too
much that you're talking about when
they're in the taverns afterwards but he
tells the greatest stories he's the
greatest storyteller he doesn't seem
like much of a politician to me but cuz
he wasn't talking he's very ill he's
suffering from from kidney stones gout
he doesn't speak his features are read
for him by Wilson his Pennsylvania
colleague so he makes it's I think it's
a confusing moment for him he's
bewildered by the rancor and the debates
and how things they think things are
settled and then all of a sudden
something's changed and we're back at
square one again
everything's unravel he's really kind of
bewildered by the whole thing
and in fact he ends by writing a friend
saying look I used to think politics was
chess was a game of chess where people
was rational he says after experiencing
the Constitutional Convention I can see
that it's a with popular politics it's
it's a game of dice he makes two
principal proposals in
the convention in two long speeches one
that all members of the executive branch
from the President on down should serve
without pay well this is long silence
following this proposal
Madison writes in his notes the motion
was tabled more out of deference to the
old man to the dignity to the old man
than to the practicality of the scheme
but he believed in that he believed that
money corrupted politics and the only
way to escape from it is to have rich
people like himself in George Washington
or after all served as
commander-in-chief without pay he uses
that example and he thought that's the
only way you're going to get away from
from from corruption in politics the
second proposal comes when he witnesses
all of this rancor in this debate and
that you know the convention comes close
to collapsing in July over the over the
representation in the Senate and he's
really the wilded by all this it's just
moving too fast for him he's an old man
and he makes the second proposal he says
I think we need to bring in a minister
every day to lead us in prayers again
there's a long pause Hamilton's supposed
to have said we don't need the
intervention of foreign powers a joke
perhaps but that was the they finally
there's a little discussion of it and
they say look if we bring a preacher in
it's going to look as if to the outside
world that we're in trouble this is very
secret of course there are guards at the
gate nobody knows there's no press
nobody knows what's going on in that
convention that bringing the preacher
would look to the world we're in trouble
which is course what Franklin thinks we
are we are in trouble so those are its
he's not he does work for the
Connecticut compromise which is
interesting because he said believer in
unicameral ISM and he's working for
compromise he wants to bring people
together and that's what and that's his
greatest strength but he finds it very
very difficult given the passions of
people that are expressed and that I
think is a shock to him because it's not
the way he thought things ought to
operate he was much more
a diplomat with two or three people in
the room that's how he says at one point
this whole revolution could have been
prevented with two or three rational men
in half an hour because that's toll
rubbish it he just doesn't understand
the passions that are involved the
structural problems that led to the
revelation he has a kind of George
Kennan view of diplomacy to just keep
the Congress out of things we could
solve the problems of the world I think
we'd have time for one more question yes
ma'am
you showed us the thick portrait of
Rutland
and we know that at his death he styled
himself he frankly a printer we talked
about this a little bit at the beginning
but I'd love to have you and help us
reconcile these two images of universe
lengthen at the end I think at the end
as I said he becomes more aware of his
printing he he actually endorses a
strike on the part of of Philadelphia
printers he sees himself he's it's a
kind of solace for all of his
disappointments to go back to his
origins and as I say he encourages his
grandson eh to stick with printing don't
try to do anything else
there is a sin and then he makes that
astonishing in his estate and is in his
will he gives justice a thousand pounds
to the City of Boston in the city of
Philadelphia for the encouragement of
artisans which has grown to be millions
of dollars which is still in existence
as far as I understand so there at the
end of his life I think he sees his his
origins as a printer giving him some
kind of emotional satisfaction in the
midst of a world which doesn't seem to
appreciate him as much as he did a five
so I think there's there's he in a way
his life comes full circle at the very
end Gordon that was absolutely
delightful as Franklin said we went to
teaches while delighting and you taught
us and delighted us at the same time
let's
now professor wood will be signing
copies of the Americanization of Ben
Franklin outside and I just also wanted
to mention that in our conversation
stitute '''l conversation series our
last one is with Ron chernow about
Alexander Hamilton and I think it's
called
is he the most underrated founding
father and that is on June 29th and I
hope you all come back for that thank
you for coming this evening and thank
you again once Gordon wood Gordon wood
is a history professor at Brown
University his books include the
radicalism of the American Revolution
the creation of the American Republic
1776 to 1787 and the American Revolution
a history his latest the Americanization
of Benjamin Franklin is published by
penguin press visit penguin com for more
information